bastion communiste depuis 1977 la ville
de la verrière passe officiellement à
droite
moins d'une semaine après sa victoire
lors du second tour des municipales
nicolas dainville a été intronisé ce
samedi 4 juillet lors du conseil
municipal d'installation organisé dans
la salle le scarabée beaucoup d'émotion
beaucoup des maisons d'émotion de
revêtir cette écharpe tricolore d'être
au service d'une ville d'avoir la
confiance des habitants font maintenant
rassemblés le temps de la campagne est
terminée c'est le temps du travail pour
agir très concrètement pour mettre en
place nos engagements sur l'éducation la
sécurité sur les grands dossiers de la
ville la maire sortante communiste nelly
du tube battu siégerait dans
l'opposition avec cinq autres membres de
sa liste
on avait plein de projets notre liste
était
enthousiaste bon
c'est comme ça maintenant on va
travailler dans nos positions et on va
faire attention à tout ce qui se fait
être attentif à ce que les intérêts des
bernois soient toujours
en premier jean yves blais arrivé
troisième de ces élections municipales
occupera lui un siège dans l'opposition
je pourrais avec madame du tout comme je
pourrais être avec monsieur dainville
tout dépendra des projets qui seront
présentés c'est tout là c'est tout
l'enjeu huit adjoints de la liste de
nicolas dainville ont également été
désignés lors de ce conseil
selon leurs compétences selon leur
origine selon leur quartier donc avec
des gens qui sont d'origine air plutôt
du bois de l'étang d'orly parc du
village
j'essaie aussi d'avoir dans les âges une
diversité avec des jambes peu plus
expérimenté d'autres un peu plus jeunes
donc on a une belle équipe
le prochain conseil municipal sera
organisé le 7 juillet prochain l'ordre
du jour le budget
[Applaudissements]